merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
s'il veut bien me répondre avant tours
en effet je souhaite interroger le
gouvernement sur le premier jihadiste
français condamné à son retour en syrie
de syrie pardon et qui a été libéré ce
lundi de la prison de condé sur sarthe
celui ci avait été condamné en novembre
2014 à sept ans de prison ferme
cette première sortie monsieur le
premier ministre va constituer à n'en
pas douter un homme aux yeux de beaucoup
de nos concitoyens à véritable test de
notre capacité de suivi et de contrôle
des djihadistes rentrer dans notre pays
détenue puis libéré après avoir purgé
leur peine
rappelons ça a été indiquée à l'instant
que 224 jihadistes sont actuellement
détenus dans les prisons françaises qui
vont sortir progressivement dès cette
année
ce produit soit j'ai une question madame
la garde des sceaux nous a indiqué à
l'instant que ce détenu comme les
prochains fera l'objet d'un suivi
judiciaire et par un juge spécialisé at
elle dit ainsi que d'un suivi
administratif
elle a cité l' obligation de pointage de
pointage l'interdiction de quitter son
domicile
pensez vous vraiment que ce dispositif
prévu pour des détenus de droit commun
suffira à rassurer les français pour
assurer leur sécurité enfin at on
vraiment les moyens d'être efficace
quand on sait qu'il faut vingt agents
pour surveiller une personne 24 heures
sur 24